Okay, you heard it here first.
Minotaurs are people.
See you next time on
Every Damn Day.
- Cut.
- I don't know, man.
I still don't think they should
be able to get married.
- Wow, dude.
- It's not natural.
Great show, guys.
Love the energy today,
but bad news,
Ryan is coming back
from his vacation today.
Yeah, so watch out,
because he is going to want
to talk about it.
Last time he left town, he
cornered me for like 10 minutes,
and I ended up missing
my hot yogurt class.
You mean, yoga.
Oh, you misheard me.
I said yogurt.
The thing I hate about Ryan
is his face and what he says.
I'm back.
Run.
I've got photos.
Shit, shit, shit, shit.
Shit. They always get
the black dude first.
Chris, is that you buddy?
You pooping?
I gotta tell you about
the bathrooms at Six Flags.
Woo. What a doozy.
This is the ladies' room.
Hey, check out
this caricature of me.
What am I?
George Bush?
Ahhhh!
Who wants to hear
about my vacation?
I've got water park photos
to show you.
Ah, Natasha. You gotta see this.
I gotta great one to show you.
No, please. No.
You're a monster. A monster.
Oh god. The lazy river.
No there's so many.
- (sneezes)
- Jordy!
Shit. I forgot
I'm allergic to mud.
Did you could get
a speeding ticket on a jet ski?
No, no, no, no, no.
I had a great vacation.
You ever been on a paddle boat?
- No, I haven't.
- They are a lot of fun.
I don't wanna. No, no!
Enough is enough.
I'm going to show you
these photos
whether you like it or not.
Over my dead body.
That can be arranged.
I've got photos.
(slow motion roaring)
Ow, god. My phone.
You're nothing
with your pictures, bitch.
I don't have insurance on this.
You started it. I finished it.
Family plan.
Hey Hanna.
Ever heard of the cloud?
Yeah!
(laughing)